we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
sometimes it would be better to live
with that hope without ever finding the
story
this is not the story you wanted to be
this story
will eat you alive
this story
is a monster
and monsters were many faces
[Music]
gotcha all right all right joy bye-bye
bad sam lake sam thank you coming all
the way over for finland for this uh
this is so exciting alan wake too it's
been a decade fans have been asking you
for it why is now the right time to
bring them back well jeff first of all i
want to say apologies it's been raining
here in los angeles today
it's on us i like fiction fiction
leaking out into reality so sorry
anyway yeah 10 years over 10 years uh
wanting to make this streaming of making
it we've been iterating on the concept
and we know fans have been asking for it
we've been a bit protective we knew this
is going to be a pretty scary experience
now we are convinced
everybody is ready you are ready what
kind of game are we gonna get for the
sequel can you tell us something about
it yeah we are breaking new crown here
this is going to be remedy's first ever
survival horror game
our take on the chandra the first game
had horror elements to it but it was an
action game yeah and we feel that this
is the perfect genre to bring together
the story and gameplay closer than ever
before because the story horror story is
at the very heart of this and it's
psychological layered deep mystery
i you know you are such an incredible
visionary i can't wait to see what
you're doing with this game i know you
said to me a while ago this was your
dream project and i'm so honored that we
got to announce this here at the game
awards so we're going to hear more next
year i think right yes we you know
fit into the theme yes we're going to go
dark okay for a while to work on this
yeah we'll be back next year
summertime okay uh to show more all
right summer 2022 more on alan wake too
sam thank you so much for that
announcement thank you very exciting all
right well now i'd like